[Music]
megan is up now in green bay wisconsin
megan how can we help
hi
i am so honored to talk to you guys well
thank you what's going on all right so
my husband has been employed for 20
years with the same company longer than
we've been married actually um and his
employer is implementing a surcharge on
insurance costs for those who are not
receiving the covet shot
um which we definitely do not want
and so we're trying to figure out we we
don't know how much the surcharge is
going to be um and we're just looking
for some guidance as to where to go from
here if we should just kind of wait the
boat or if he should maybe just start
looking a little bit to see what else is
out there in case it gets you know
let me ask you this if this wasn't
coming down the pike
would he be thinking about moving
on no he really likes what he does yeah
um
i this is
i'm going to try to not get involved in
this emotionally and and help you walk
through this
because on one hand you guys don't want
to get it you don't want to get the shot
and uh on the other hand you don't want
to you know get hit really hard and take
on an expense like this and he wasn't
looking wasn't thinking about looking
prior to this so this really puts you in
a tough situation but i think this comes
down to to your priorities
and uh you know
i think at the end of the day they need
to tell you what the what the cost is
going to be and then you weigh the cost
literally weigh the cost okay
in order to stay in this job that he
really enjoys
there's going to be an added monthly
expense now that i'm getting hit with
um how long is that going to last we
don't know the answer to that you know
is it going to be forever you know
who knows
i think you have to weigh that um
while you're weighing that and waiting
for that information i would be looking
though i'll tell you that
yeah there's two pieces of this there's
the ethical component of do i want to
work for a place that has these values
and if overall he agrees with them
ethically and he goes all right this is
something i got to deal with and it
basically you know turns into a 200 pay
cut right if it's 10 15 bucks a month
now if it's i can't imagine it's
anything large i'm not gonna charge you
a hundred dollars i would hope not um
but then you weigh it and go all right
am i willing to take this
little pay cut uh to stay at a job that
i truly love and this is just an
annoyance that i'm gonna deal with as
part of it but if you're like hey i
can't agree with them ethically anymore
i've gotta leave that's your decision
that you have to make yeah
yeah i i think this is tough um
and i gotta tell you now that i think
about it george you know i i wouldn't be
surprised if it's not a hefty
bump because i'm going to tell you what
this amounts to this is a penalty
and companies are saying we think
everybody should be vaccinated
and
we're telling you that you
need to
because i think delta airlines came out
they were the first i think major
company for this kind of thing was like
hey we're gonna hit you with a with a
premium uh on your health care because
of all the uh the implications they're
saying yeah but i think it comes down to
a penalty
and i don't know it may not be it may
not be insignificant it may be a
significant number and in that case
unfortunately turns into a budget line
item your values and your money are
driving this decision and if you got to
move on you got to move on